I scan them in the game that's when I'm  playing I look exactly like me do you  play with you or do you play with other  dudes I play as myself and my player  yeah how are the ratings right now my  ratings man he'd be giving me all the  badges and everything so I'm lit what  what does gaming mean to you it's like a  reward thing for me like after breakfast  I'll start making beats and working on  Beats and stuff and then when I'm done I  need a break I'm like perfect I earned  it I'm gonna go play video games or to  kill time like if I'm waiting for  somebody for an hour I can kill a kill  time play a couple games of FIFA or  something oh so you got your Madden 2K  FIFA you got it all locked down yeah NHL  too